welcome stanford alumni tigers googlers
friends and guests my name is chris lowe
stanford business school class of 1991
and the events chair of the stanford gsb
asian alumni chapter
along with denise pack gsb class of 1985
and our chapter president moderator
sunyu
mba 1993 ivy chu msm
2009 kathleen layman of the gsb alumni
relations office
jennifer liu asians in finance at google
and norm leon
asian erg at gopro we're all delighted
to welcome you to tonight's event
the untold story behind altos ventures
a vc firm that invested in both roblox
and koopa
two of the 2021's biggest ipos
we're very excited that ho han
anthony and larry are joining us tonight
it truly is an honor and a privilege
that we have them here to share their
story with our community
the altos venture story starts in 1996
with stanford business school roots
a single limited partner three gsb
professors and a 30 million dollar
fund investing in early stage technology
companies
this early support came from a group of
surprising partners
an unexpected community of investors who
also
understood the idea of being
marginalized today
altos ventures manages more than 10
billion dollars in regulatory assets
what learnings can we apply from altos's
experiences
securing their early funds what is their
investment purpose
and philosophy what can the unconnected
asian american entrepreneur do to
overcome unwarranted stereotypes
and successfully raise a vc round
tonight's
tonight's panel will examine these
questions and many others from a
practical
on the ground perspective by the way
please note that this webinar is being
recorded
if you have any questions for the
moderators or panelists
please enter them in the q a box let me
start by introducing our moderators
sunyu is a best-selling author and
expert on innovation and design
his book iconic advantage challenges
businesses from fortune 500
to companies to venture-backed startups
to refocus their
innovation priorities on building
greater iconicity
and offers deeper insights on
establishing
timeless distinction and relevance he
most recently served as a global vp of
innovation
and officer at vf corporation current
organization to
over 30 global apparel companies
including the north face
vans timberland nautica and wrangler
prior to this he worked as a general
manager at the clorox company and
chiquita brands
as a consultant at banning company and
as a founder of numerous ventureback
startups
in addition soon recently published an
article on for forbes titled
who owns the aapi brand from stereotypes
to stories
i hope you get a chance to read it ivy
chu
is the senior director of digital
strategy at royal bank of canada
where she leads the product team in
building a digital platform to provide
financial services and advice to over 2
million clients
prior to joining rbc ib launched and
scaled the product consulting team at
linkedin
in asia pacific and was a management
consultant in bannon companies
southeast asian practice ivy has also
served as a guest speaker at the
stanford business school in recent years
on topics of
organizational culture and employee
engagement
so without further ado soon please take
it away
thank you very much chris and i'd like
to take a moment and really acknowledges
chris's leadership
without you we couldn't pull this
together and
i also wanted to just say that uh we've
had an amazing
turnout so i want to thank the audience
we actually have
almost 700 people registered for this
event and that's uh usually we're around
300 so this is about double what we
normally
see so a lot of demand and enthusiasm
about this event and i'm very excited to
be able to moderate this event
it is an extreme pleasure because and
privilege because
what we're going to be doing today is
really talking about some great stories
from the aapi community
and what's really great about telling
stories and promoting is that we've got
some
wonderful actual heroes behind these
stories
in terms of what they went through to
get to where they are today and let me
tell you it wasn't always
easy and just as important we're going
to be talking about stories of allyship
where support came from other
communities to really help us get to
where we are today so these are
wonderful stories that we can't wait to
share with you
now what's our goal today obviously we
want to learn from these amazing heroes
and the supporters that were behind them
and i know
from that you're probably thinking oh
i'm going to take away some best
practices about being an entrepreneur
or maybe even starting the bc fund
myself or
maybe leadership skills that i might
apply to my teams
of course we're going to cover those
things but what i really want to share
with you
is maybe another point of view and it
was actually captured in the title that
chris created for this program today and
the single word i want to focus is
focus us on is the idea of untold
you see there are untold heroes in this
story
there are surprising supporters that
came to the rescue of these heroes
there were untold moments where i think
some of our heroes were looking down at
the abyss
and thinking what are they going to do
with what's face what they're facing
and then obviously there are untold
lessons
inside of that and that's what we really
want to focus on today
is the untold whys behind the whats
so i would ask his audience pay
attention to those because i think
beyond learning some practical skills
and some best practices
practices i think we're going to learn
some real life lessons that are going to
be
able to be applied in whatever you're
doing
and in terms of whatever type of
situation you might be facing
okay um so let me introduce the
panelists here
and i'm gonna start off by actually not
giving you the bios you can find those
on linkedin
and let me just say obviously there's
some themes they all the three partners
we're going to talk to today they all
work for
altos ventures okay we know that part uh
another common theme is uh they all
graduate
from the stanford business school um and
surprisingly
all three of them have consulting
backgrounds i don't know if that's a
cooler to success or to to some of the
early failures that they had
okay but those are the commonalities
um i also want to share some stuff that
you may not be able to read through the
bios
um i've spent a lot of time actually
i've known host since that we both
graduated from college we were in our
first job together at banning company
um and i've gotten to know both han and
anthony through this process
and there are some themes about both
them as a team but also all those
ventures that i think is really
important
first and foremost if you were to meet
them sitting
next to them on a you know in an
airplane or just on the street
you would have no idea that they're
behind one of the most successful
vc firms in in the entire us in fact
globally i would say they're probably in
terms of returns
in korea in the last few years what an
amazing track record
but if you met any one of them you would
find them down to earth
very humble and very very much
very focused on you actually is is is uh
one of the other qualities that they all
share um the other thing is they're all
actually very proud not to be venture
capitalists or
all the accomplishments that they have
they're proud to be parents
they're proud of their kids and their
families
and they're very involved and active in
their communities
uh so these are individuals who are very
much
involved in our community and and lastly
i'll say something
um i asked each one of them if they
weren't doing this
okay what would they be doing and all
three of them answered
individually they answered the same with
the same answer which is
i would continue to do this even if you
didn't pay me
because they love what they're doing and
um i was in a conversation with han a
couple days ago and he shared something
with me goes
you know every day i get to sit across
from people
that are people that you would meet in
ted talks
people that are going to be future
visionaries people that are trying to
change the world
people that have passion in terms of it
you know index
like 200 percent of what other people
have and people that have courage
because they want to try something
new how can you not love your job
when that's what you're surrounded with
every single
day and to be able to be the confidants
for those type of people han said it was
very humbling and i think that was
probably very true for both anthony
and for ho when i asked them the same
questions so
if you're an entrepreneur wouldn't you
love to go pitch
to altos ventures knowing that the way
they view you they view you as
future visionaries as people who are
going to be up there
during the ted talks so that's
what makes i think altos really unique
is that humanity that they bring both to
their personal lives
but also to why they're doing their
profession okay
so with that as a context and with that
as sort of the knowledge of who
this team is how did this team begin
and so i'm going to turn that over to
you ho if you can sort of help answer
how did altos
become altos wow soon that is such an
unbelievable introduction i think i'm
going to have to knock us down a couple
of pegs
so that we can start from the beginning
but
it's it's great thanks for having us and
i've known soon forever since our very
first job is out of college
so it's been a amazing journey that
we've taken together over all these
decades
so so my personal journey with alto
started with a phone call in the fall of
han gave me a call and han said hey you
know remember professor
jin wong from gsb you know he's got
this investor he who needs help in
venture capital and i think han called
me because he didn't know any vcs
probably other than myself
and i happen to have done some vc work
before after bain
prior to gsb at a firm called trinity
ventures in the early 90s
and so we started talking about it and
and we actually put together a little
business plan
and the recommendation to this investor
was oh you shouldn't get into vc right
now this is not a good time
you know because you know 95 it was
after the netscape ipo
to me i didn't know any better that felt
like wow very frothy market
you know compared to 1991 which was a
recession year i think the entire
industry maybe raised a billion dollars
of funding
the entire industry right now we have
companies that are raising billions in
funding you know potentially in a single
round
so so anyway that was the advice and the
investor came back to us and said well
you know why don't you guys
maybe get started in a small way and if
it
if it turns out that the market crashes
later we could put a lot of money behind
you guys
it's like well really you know and they
were doing big deals like they put
200 million dollars into one company
they could do
that kind of a big deal so 30 million to
them felt like a small thing and said
geez if if we get involved
maybe we can we could take advantage of
market
opportunities on the road so that's kind
of how we got started
and you know we took a pretty
uh customary approach we were just this
tiny fund
we were focused on small deals where we
could be hands-on investors very
old-fashioned venture capital
and we thought that gave us a little bit
of an advantage because it's an
advantage of small size
all these venture funds were starting to
get bigger and bigger they couldn't
afford to spend too much time on these
tiny little deals
and we really wanted to partner with the
best vcs
but we didn't want to follow them into
their deals because we didn't think they
would show us any of their best deals
like who are we like bunch of young
kids from korea like who who the heck
are we right
but if we did the work early on and if
we got them to come into our deals
hopefully we could learn from them and
of course investing
getting started in 96 january of 96 is
when we all got started
that was a pretty good time you know
because just about every deal we did it
seemed like
we were getting big step ups and
valuation from
from uh from kind of some famous
investors right
so that was that was pretty good and
then what ended up happening though was
you know we've gone through so many
near-death moments in 98 we kind of
faced our first existential crisis
and that was related to the if people
remember the long-term capital
management blow up
related to the russian ruble crisis and
the asian financial crisis
well it really hit korea very hard and
our single investor was out of korea
and almost put them out of business and
they were having a very difficult time
meeting the capital call commitments
and so we thought we had this fund but
we really didn't have any money that we
could draw on
and so we um we scrambled and trying to
figure out how do we survive how do we
even pay our salaries and rent
and and we were able to find the silicon
valley bank
who looked at our portfolio and they
said hey look look at all these
good companies because they bank
everybody and they work with a lot of
the vcs that were co-investors in our
deals and so hey these guys are really
good vcs that invested in your deals
that validated
your companies and they were banking
many of our companies and so they
decided to give us a 10 million
line of credit which is kind of crazy
in today's regulatory environment that
would never happen
but it went all the way to the ceo and
the ceo approved it
so that gave us this lifeline 10 million
dollar lifeline to pay our salaries pay
our rent and to be able to continue to
support
some of our companies as they did more
financings and then as the bubble
continued on
into the well into the 90s and you know
things started to clear up again our
portfolio continued to perform
and our lp was back in business and so
all of these things were happening and
we thought
geez you know maybe we're pretty good at
this uh and then maybe
maybe we should be expanding you know
and that's what led us to anthony but
before i introduce anthony
so in 99 kind of two things happened
uh one is i went to the berkshire
hathaway shareholder meeting for the
first time
and of course we had all known about
berkshire hathaway and
warren buffett from professor jack
mcdonald who was one of the our advisors
from day one but i had never really
spent too much time
studying him and just being there that
weekend in the peak of the bubble in may
and hearing how he operated and how that
whole community
operated it was so different than the
little silicon valley bubble
right and so that was kind of the
beginning of a journey of
how do we marry the fundamental
investing principles of warren buffett
with what we were doing in silicon
valley vc and
and people that that couldn't be done
and that was kind of a dumb idea
buffett doesn't even like tech and he
doesn't like vc so how can we combine
it but that kind of got us on a 20-year
journey to figure that out and we'll
talk about that later
the other thing that happened in 99 was
i had this interesting conversation with
one of the
original partners at trinity and he was
on the board of starbucks
when the company went public and he had
kept all of his shares
all of his board shares as well as his
distributions from the funds
and the company went public in 92 and i
thought it was wow that's kind of
remarkable you
never sold a single share so why is it
that the rest of the partners and the
rest of the partnership sold
right well vcs have all these pressures
to get the exits get liquidity
and and you know soon after ipo
basically you sell or distribute
and we thought geez you know if you look
at the value creation
in the venture industry and in tech in
general
so much the value creation happens after
ipo
and how do we capture that value how do
we create these enduring companies
and continue the compounding for decades
so that's another
little seed of an idea that started back
in 99 and it took us 20 years to kind of
figure out how to do that
and we'll get into that a little bit
more as well
and so going back to uh uh uh
how anthony comes in so we're thinking
about basically
expanding now we're doing so well and
and and
and we wanted to recruit anthony because
he was one of the best marketing people
we knew he was in charge of marketing at
evolve software which was
our very first investment in 96. he left
the company
prior to ipo and then he pitched us in a
startup
and we turned him down for that startup
but then he got term sheets from two
top tier vcs and he came back to us and
said hey look i got term sheets from
these
famous vcs i still want you involved
like why don't you participate
and we turned them down a second time
because we said well no no that's not
our model we don't follow other vcs
like we want them to follow us right so
we turned them down second time
but we really liked anthony and we
started to
think about basically you know calling
on them when we thought that the company
maybe was kind of
uh on the ropes right it's like so how
is that startup going by the way
right and anyway we convinced anthony to
join us in 2000 he thought we were going
to be this
you know very successful vc we had all
these ipos in the works
and then it all kind of started falling
apart but anthony
joined us and he stuck with us and then
we could kind of
take it uh take it from there on some of
the lessons
of the fundraising in that difficult.com
era
and and basically dealing with the
triage basically of
all these difficult uh uh situations
that we had to go through for the next
several years before we could
raise a fund so take it away anthony
well before anthony jones i want to just
summarize what i heard because there's a
lot there's it's pretty amazing
when you guys started it was sort of an
idea you had this great lp
and you guys were off and running and
then basically let's say the global
financial crisis happened and then you
guys went through hell
okay your first hell right and then from
there your lp kind of disappeared on you
right and you didn't
and it's really interesting you guys
actually had to get bridge financing
which most
most of the portfolio companies have to
a vc firm actually had to go and get
bridge financing
to actually survive and to thrive and
then
i guess you were able to turn the corner
on that for a few years
and from that i guess you painted his
rosy picture
and convinced anthony to join you but we
all know what happened in 2000 with your
entire portfolio if everyone can just
sort of
you know take a time capsule and go back
to the heydays of great valuations and
all those dot-com parties
you remember every every every night
there was a dot-com party right
what happened a few months after that is
what anthony
you inherited correct
that's exactly right soon and i remember
walking into the office the very office
behind
a hoe there and looking on a whiteboard
in han's office and he had written up
three ipos three companies that were
going to go public
uh two of them ended up going public one
of them did not go public
and we lost money on all three of them
including the two that went public
and it was shortly before that that i
had when i had joined i told my wife you
know
i think i finally made it i made it to
the venture capital promised land
and we're gonna make millions and i'm
gonna be sitting in this office writing
checks
and saying yes or no to companies coming
in the door
and i learned a lesson very quickly that
venture capital is not a buy side job
venture capital is a sell side job and
for the next
five years i got on the road with han
and ho and
we we went out and tried to raise money
and sell and to this day that's that's
our mentality is we are in the sell side
business we have to convince
investors to have faith in us we have to
convince entrepreneurs to take our money
we have to
convince candidates to join our
companies
so uh that that was one of the first
hard lessons i learned soon
and for the first five years i didn't
make a single investment
at altos we were just trying to survive
so you talked about the first time that
our lp kind of went out of business and
we got the bridge loan
uh shortly after the financial crisis
they went out of business again
with us and said you know we we can't
come through on that 100 million dollars
that we promised you so
my very first job instead of celebrating
these ipos was to hit the road and
figure out how to fill them in how to
find
another investor to take their place
which is something that is rarely done
and something that we just had to learn
how to do so
we were successful in that and met some
great people along the way
and then after that the next job was to
actually go raise a new fund
uh and and this is the fund that we set
out to raise in 2001
and uh i remember
that you know most people say well you
know
raising a venture fund is not that hard
you just go to the lps and
they give you commitments takes about
three to six months
well it took us four years from front to
end to raise 68 million dollars
so i think we set some kind of record
for time spent
per dollar raised we certainly spent uh
set some kind of record for for lps that
we met along the way that said no to us
um you know you said 700 people
registered for this webinar i think we
met more than 700 people
along the way uh flying all around the
united states going to europe going to
asia
and you know you made a comment earlier
soon about
not recognizing us if we were sitting on
a plane that's because we were sitting
in like 21
f way back in the back and
running around trying our best to raise
money so
what did we learn during this this
period um well we learned to persevere
and uh you know we never really
questioned ourselves
because we had no choice we had no other
alternative we weren't going to go to
another fund we weren't going to go
do another job once you become a venture
capitalist you're pretty much
unqualified to do anything else
so we just had to make it work is that
one of the lessons
that last month yes absolutely so those
of you thinking about venture
two things uh four years potentially to
raise money you're on the sell side not
on the buy
side and once you're a venture
capitalist you're kind of i don't know
ex you're kind of excommunicated from
every other job
you're your very last job it should be
your last job for good and bad reasons
so i you know i think we learned
something in the fundraising process
that is
is applicable to anybody out there who's
thinking of raising a fund or even
raising a fund for a company
and that is that you have to have a few
things you have you have to have
a strategy that people love you have to
have a team that
people love and maybe is is known and
has done some things together
and you have to have an excellent track
record unfortunately we had none of
those three things
in 2001 we had a track record that was
not yet realized and actually negative
at the time
after the bubble we had a strategy that
was sort of
avis we'll try harder and then we had a
team that was
totally unknown to the limited partner
community because before that we had had
only one
lp so we really had to make people like
us we really had to persevere we really
had to go
through many many no's to get to yeses
uh and in fact some of our
our very best lp said no to us several
times
and then the fourth factor is sometimes
there's an x factor
sometimes you get lucky sometimes
there's some kind of connection
sometimes there's a special mandate
sometimes there's there's something that
an investor is trying to achieve or they
have a thesis on your space or your kind
of firm
and that's a little bit what happened to
us in 2002 and 2003.
so in that period there was some
interest from the pension fund community
working with fund of funds to look for
emerging managers
these new kind of younger funds
some of them spinning out of larger
funds and
emerging managers was also a pseudonym
in some cases for
minority managers and in our industry
you know minority managers were
generally thought of as african-american
or hispanic and three asian guys
on the road you know we didn't really
fit into the mainstream
and we really didn't fit into the
classic minority definition
and i'm sure many people in this
audience have had that feeling before
but we were definitely
kind of in that awkward middle we were
lucky enough
to come across some people in the
limited partner community
who were thinking very far forward in
terms of
what needed to happen to the industry
the kind of diversity that needed to be
in the industry
and the kinds of people that they ought
to maybe take a bet on
people without a great track record
strategy or team
and we were very lucky to to run into a
gentleman gentleman
named lawrence morris dr larry morris
who's going to join us on the call here
and before i introduce larry who just
popped on here
i'll say that we had all sorts of
experiences during our fundraising trip
we we i remember we fell downstairs we
got stuck in airports uh in one
particularly bad meeting
we walked out of the office totally
dejected this was in santa monica
california
and literally a bird pooped on my suit
so
it was just one of those providence
things that we just had to
walk we just had to work through but
then we met larry
and and larry is such a gentleman it was
it was a it was a long courtship we met
him in 2001
he committed to our fund in 2003 and we
didn't
even launch the fund until 2005 so he
was
very patient with us and i don't think
we gave him a dollar back
until much later than that so larry's
stuck with us all these years
and uh i want to hand it over to him now
well thank you for that introduction
anthony it's such a
privilege and a pleasure to be with you
guys this evening uh listening to you
tell those early war stories
uh really took me back and in some sense
reminded me
very much of our own firm's initial
beginnings when
my partner joanna price and i co-founded
fairview back in
1994 we had a very simple thesis
we saw an opportunity set of what we
believe to be
talented capable experienced diverse
fund managers
who had hitherto not had significant
success
accessing the broader capital market and
a very small number of institutional
investors who had at least indicated
some interest some openness
to identifying non-correlated assets for
their portfolios
so we thought we could bridge the two it
didn't take us quite as long as it took
you guys to raise a fund three but it
did take us two years
out of all sorts of meetings and we have
kind of war stories and scar tissue of
our own but we raised that fund
the first fund in september of we closed
in september of 1994
it was just shy of 100 million dollars
and
of course today like you we managed 10
billion dollars and some
30 customized commingle uh funds and
funds as well as
customized single client funds but at
the time that we met altos back as
anthony pointed out in 2001
we had three funds under management the
altos team at that time had two
all from as they've noted a single
investor and they were on the verge of
attempting to
engage in this first broad institutional
capital raise and that would become fund
three
so we as anthony pointed out we did take
our time to get to know them
um but that's our process sometimes
that's shorter than others depending on
what your touch points
are if you will um but it starts with
the people
and so as we got to know these guys over
time there were a number of things about
them that were particularly compelling
starting with the people obviously these
guys have very stellar
educational credentials they'd gone to
princeton and harvey mudd and west point
they all had mbas from stanford but then
they'd had work experiences at a number
of really
world-class firms and companies there
was bain and booz allen and
coovers and librarian and mckenzie
proctor and gamble silicon graphics
trinity ventures whom we knew well so
they've been exposed to and succeeded in
some very challenging and demanding
environments so kind of point number one
the second thing was and this may strike
you as counter-intuitive but it was
important for us they made a number of
mistakes in their inaugural
efforts as fund managers and that's not
at all uncommon or unusual for
first-time
fund managers but the thing about these
guys that was somewhat different and it
was
obvious from the beginning is that they
were very methodical
rigorous and disciplined about
identifying
their errors and learning from them so
we had this sense that there was this
nascent culture of continuous learning
within the firm that embraced that this
was important to them and we saw that as
extremely positive they developed a very
clear sense of
the things that they did well and that
they intended to build on
and they also had a very clear sense of
the things that didn't serve them well
which they intended
to discard so we caught him at an
inflection point
if you will and that was important the
third thing was
as a team and this is really important
for first-time fund managers
because one of the one of the primary
risks you take in our business
with first-time fund managers is that
the team won't cohere
under the pressures of this business
people don't understand how hard and
grinding
this business is and these guys have
faced some very significant
not one or two i mean a number of very
significant
adversities is as whole characterized in
and i think so accurately
near-death experiences and yet they
hadn't turned on one of them
right and they had an abandoned ship so
it was obvious they were committed to
this common effort
they were committed to helping each
other becoming better at what they do
and that was a real star um
you know kind of on the ledger if you
will from our perspective as we
evaluated them
the fourth thing was it was clear that
they had a real discerning eye
um for identifying and attracting high
quality
differentiated deal flow i mean if you
ever spend time with
ho han anthony and listen to these guys
deconstruct
an opportunity um it's very clear to you
that their investment
acumen and aptitude are just
just top shelf they're just really sharp
they think well as investors and and we
we
you know we were able to to pick up on
that and it was important to us
and lastly they had surrounded
themselves with a small group of
a very wise loyal uh seasoned mentor
advisors
from both stanford business school as
well as the engineering faculty
um including of course when they've
referenced the inestimable
professor jack mcdonald who many people
on this call will
you know know from his legendary courses
in private equity and investment
management and
entrepreneurial finance so ultimately we
reached the conclusion that this was a
team that was deeply committed to
working with talented entrepreneurs
they wanted to build world-class
companies but they were
equally intent on building an enduring
venture investment franchise
and that was appealing to us and we
decided we wanted to be
uh supportive of that effort and so
ultimately we committed to
that next one and the and the fund after
that uh
as anthony pointed out it took them two
years
um to get to a first close we kept our
movement for that period of time uh
there were certainly moments during that
when my partners looked at me and
wondered if i was
crazy for doing this
but i really believed in this team
um and was committed i had conviction
around it was committed to doing it
and so we stuck with them that the last
point i'll i'll make and and then i'll
shut up
soon before you kind of give me the hook
there was also a sense of of
identification i mean
you know anthony talks about the 700
plus you know kind of meetings if you
will
because we committed early we fielded a
number
of calls if you will diligence calls
from people who were evaluating
the altos opportunity for themselves and
you know people sometimes ask some
pretty weird
uh questions that are pretty revealing
and it becomes obvious to you that some
of the things that people were concerned
about or that were causing them
reluctance or hesitance weren't rational
and it reminded me very much of the
experience joanne and i had had as we
were raising our first fund
going in and out of a number of
environments where after a couple of
minutes it was clear to you
people's eyes would glaze over they
weren't taking you seriously
they were applying huge discount factors
not simply to what you said but to who
you were
in some cases it was obvious within
moments of walking in the door
and it was clear when you walked out the
door that you'd never hear from those
people again
um so we had a sense that some of what
they were facing
uh you know had elements of that
involved and
and that too quite frankly made us all
the more determined to be supportive
of them and of course as they pointed
out um they've obviously gone on to be
tremendously successful we've been more
than amply
rewarded for uh for our patients uh and
we're grateful quite frankly to have
been a part of their journey so
with that i'll shut up soon no thank you
larry and larry i know you and i spoke
and
and i think that last point is really an
important one
and that's where the basis of allyship
was formed was sort of this ability to
have empathy
for being discounted before you even
step into a room before you even open
your mouth
just because of who you are what you
look like and
i just found that very powerful and
i know the other things that you said
are important and by the way those of
you who are either going to be trying to
raise money which almost every
entrepreneur or any any
uh lp or sort um venture capital
uh wannabe uh will be doing and you
should take
uh the the factors that you mentioned
but i think that last one is so
important in terms of
um and for you it wasn't actually
traditional um because i think
you had a slightly different mandate and
when you had to go back and tell your
lps actually
i'm investing in an asian uh venture
capital firm
that was probably probably surprising
but not surprising too at the same time
no yeah no it wasn't as surprising as as
you might think for the following reason
uh one of the things and and there was
no way for the altos guys to know this
at the time they were
getting to know us anthony may know this
now because he subsequently became
really active himself and involved with
the national association of investment
companies
but my partner and co-founder joanne
price had been president of the national
association of investment companies for
a decade before we teamed up and i had
been in the business since 1983.
the naic as an association
at the time had some hundred plus member
firms
most of which were minority enterprise
small business investment companies and
the people running those companies
were african-american asian-american
hispanic
americans native americans so
meeting the altos team was not something
you know kind of out of line or strange
if you will
uh for me or for us at fairview
we were simply focused on what is it
that they bring what
differentiates them what particular
special sauce
or special sandbox that they define in
which
they will take on all comers and we have
a compelling indicia that they're likely
to be incredibly successful
that's what we focused on we i'll say
this last thing i mean
there's a there's a reason our firm is
called and named fairview
we chose that name deliberately because
we wanted it to be the case
that whenever any individual set foot in
our door
and sat at our table if they came to the
table with a compelling investment
thesis
they had talent and experience that
suggested to us
that they could be successful they
merited a fair view
full stop the end we could care less
what your packaging is
talent is distributed across all groups
and the problem with the capital markets
all too often in this country
the way they have functioned
historically they're becoming somewhat
better
but they're still skewed to a certain
degree is that they ignore
huge repositories of capital huge
repositories of talent
talent present themselves in packaging
that just doesn't look like what they're
used to
um and they miss it and they're missing
out on opportunities and it just
absolutely drives us nuts sometimes
um you know and so look if you're going
to sit there and miss
out on you know extremely talented team
like altos because you're
blinded by their packaging uh or because
you bring certain biases to your
to your evaluative processes and this
dna is shame on you
so thank you so much larry and that's
such a such a really inspirational story
and
i know for altos and i talked to the
team
um you were their first institutional
investor and in many ways um
you validated uh the rest of the
race i think which took i think four
years to raise and
and so that that's very surprising the
fact that you stuck with them for those
uh you know two or three years after you
committed
is truly amazing so anyway great story
thank you larry for your participation
and
you know without you and uh without the
team's
ability to i think learn from adversity
as you're saying in terms of this
mindset of continuous improvement
without the team not learning how to
support each other through the adversity
and not turning on each other i think
that's
incredible and then having as you said a
network of great mentors to sort of fall
back on
right um you know in some ways they if i
look at
my analogy to them is they were a
startup right
and they were a startup that was going
through the the hiccups and the
ups and downs of a normal startup and
anyone's probably been in a real startup
has no
you know a real startup that it wasn't
just a unicorn from day one
uh you're gonna go through those moments
of near death
and that's right the fact that you were
able to support them
you know that has actually allowed them
to really blossom and
and so that was kind of first decade for
altos a lot of
a few highs and quite a few lows and
deep lows right
and as as from that experience obviously
a lot of great lessons learned i love
how anthony talked about sort of the
three criteria that people look at
investing how you guys didn't meet any
of them anthony is great
and then larry your sort of five or six
star qualities that you look for for an
investor
so i'm curious all these lessons learned
right in terms of what people are
looking for what you were looking for
larry
huh i'm gonna turn over to you this next
second decade so this is sort of
after the to call 2004 on
how did you apply those learnings to
have some of the amazing
sort of successes that you've had uh
both in korea but also in the us
so you know between all these rejections
we obviously had
a lot of time to talk amongst ourselves
to talk about what we did wrong mostly
um and you know i think
in the early days when we thought we
were good
you know we were i think fairly smart
enough to
latch onto lots of interesting business
ideas
and we realized that as long as we got
the
sort of the founders of these companies
to make a bit of progress on management
hiring
and potentially offer themselves up to a
to be very open to getting a ceo
into their companies as long as we got
them prepared and we put that package
together
we took it to a you know sort of we call
uh
the larger venture funds traditional
venture funds
they would mark up the price and they
invested a high valuation they put the
new ceo in then
the bankers start showing up and the
companies were ready to go public it was
literally like that during the bubble
days of internet
and so we obviously thought that was the
formula for being a
very good venture capitalist and when
the rug was pulled
underneath from us we real in
all these companies and anthony
mentioned you know all these companies
that were ready to go public
you know they just went away and we made
you know we lost money on these and
we realized okay that was obviously a
wrong formula
so we got to we got to think about what
so we actually you know
who talked about going to see warren
buffett so we talked about hey you know
the stuff we actually learned at school
about you know maybe cash flow positive
business
building one by one great founders
maybe that's the model we need to go to
so we sat down and
and i distinctly remember all of us
talking about okay
let's you know we had shitty luck
replacing founders so let's
let's invest in a founder and let's not
even think about
replacing the founders if the other guys
want to replace the founders
we should almost always have an allergic
reaction to it
let's just make sure we could support
the founders
and second thing was you know we just
hate being
sort of i guess set aside by
larger investors so that means
let's make sure our companies are fairly
capital efficient
we could we could turn on a dime to sort
of sustain
you know with whatever capital we raise
at that time
and so with these two formula we started
on a fund
and and after a while you know we
i think we went a bit overboard because
then we realized our companies are
fairly capital efficient but they're not
really growing that quickly
so i i think i think it was anthony that
actually brought it up hey but i think
we need to put growth
in there and we said you know that's a
great idea
let's make that into another sort of and
and that literally
kicked in sort of sort of middle towards
the end of the first
institutional fund and and
and basically we started applying those
lessons
and we actually ended up putting a very
high bar
on the founder part just because now we
can't replace them
so we have to be fairly sure about
them being able to take the company
for many many years so then it was more
around
what can we do to make sure the founder
could take the company from ground zero
maybe perhaps all the way
into the ipo and that just meant
a lot of encouragement a lot of coaching
training
at the same time you have to have
certain ways for founders to
cash out so they you know they don't
suffer for a very long time so we came
up with various innovative
ways and we were much more open to those
kind of ideas than
probably other people so that they could
stay for a long time and and become
successful
and you know i think with all this
then we realized our universe of
companies that we want to invest in you
know it's a maybe a small subset
of a lot of other great companies and if
other people
invest in in a company they put the new
management team in place and they become
successful we're like that's fine
because as long as the way our companies
do well
we really don't care what other people
do and so i think we
ended up developing a fairly distinct
way of
identifying what we like what we don't
like
and that didn't mean that what we liked
was better than
others but it was just the ones that we
like
and and and i think we were able to stay
focused on it so if i were to just put
like one
example company where you know we got to
put
a lot of these into practice was uh ua
brothers
out in korea um you know when we met the
founder
the founder didn't you know as larry
said
it he didn't come with a complete
packaging
he um he had a furniture company
online furniture company which he failed
uh he was in debt uh and so he went back
to
work for a a large company
so that he could pay off some of these
debt and
and meanwhile he and his brother
you know decided he wanted to tackle a
business uh sort of and the restaurant
mobile
he wanted mobile and restaurant business
so that's when he started
uh ooa brothers and
he didn't go to uh you know top college
in korea he went to two-year design
school
uh and and when we met with him
you know he did all the hard things all
the labor-intensive stuff to get the
restaurants in place and
you know we heard the story and we
thought hey this
is the kind of entrepreneur we i think
we typically love and
we invested in him uh and then after a
while
you know he got to he got the company to
about
10 million dollars run rate and
he's like hey i got the company to this
i'm not the guy to take it to a hundred
million dollar level so let's
search for a new he actually suggested
getting a new ceo and we said
you're crazy i think you could take the
company to a hundred million dollar
level
and i think he stayed up every night
he woke up early every day to read tons
of books on leadership
how to run a company you know then you
know you see him
with a desk with wheels on
and if a product side had problems he
just literally took his desk to where
the product team sat
and he would it just worked with him and
if the engineering team had problems he
just took his desk
worked with him i'm i'm pretty sure that
came out of some book
that he read but he literally
learned on the job uh to
you know make himself a better ceo uh
and you know the other day he's like hun
the person that just sort of reconfirms
sort of our um you know maybe
the way we think about the business and
growing the business
it worked out not all businesses work
out like that but
and i think anthony has another sort of
a story on
on roblox as well very probably move on
though a couple of other things because
between the 10 million when he thought
he couldn't take it to a hundred
and a billion he also came back to han
at a hundred million and said wow we're
doing amazingly well
but you have the wrong man for the job
because i don't see how i could take it
to a billion
right but now that he's at a billion now
he now he finally is thinking so you
know these things happen
you just don't decide you don't you
can't figure it out up front
you just kind of figure it out along the
way the other thing that happened is
by the time they hit 10 million there
was a lot of pressure from the board
to take the company to profitability and
make it public because in korea you
could take a tiny little company public
and you have to be profitable and so it
was
it was the march orders were to get to
profitability so you could take it
public by the time they hit 20 million
in revenue
and we thought that was the wrong
approach uh hey this is actually working
well this is the time to actually step
on the gas
right and by the time we got to 100
million we were profitable
right and now it's it's quite
interesting because
in silicon valley we're viewing these as
these very
old school pragmatic conservative vcs
we're not like
go go go you know go big or go home
types
but in korea that was seen as wow these
guys are really aggressive silicon
valley types right because we wanted to
step on the gas at 10 million
when it's going really well but we were
not the kind of guys
to say you should burn burn burn at 100
million or a billion
is like you got to get through
profitability right and we saw the path
to profitability
and we have the same exact strategy in
silicon valley as in korea
but because the business cultures are so
different in korea we're viewed as these
aggressive company builders in silicon
valley were viewed as these conservative
pragmatic types but we have the same
exact formula same approach to building
companies
at either geography so i'll pause there
you know i want to pause also and just
just acknowledge that
i i want the audience to acknowledge
that this is a very different
investment thesis or philosophy than
what
most of the venture capital community is
exposed to or sort of follows and
i don't know if this is a marriage of
east and west i don't know if it's
warren buffett and bc but a couple of
things i pulled out from this is you
guys invest in
relationships right and i know i think
uh
i asked each one of you about the other
to and you guys all played each other
compliments which was really
amazing but what anthony says is what
han does is he spends
a lot of time with his extended family
and he described the extended family as
all the entrepreneurs and founders and
um the executives and all the companies
and he has meals with him because he
loves food and he loves
people and he has found a job that he
can combine
both of them and and so that's one of
the thesis is that you guys invest in
people and the relationships and i
thought that was very powerful
the other is that this idea of
continuous learning both for you guys
as a vc fund but also in your companies
and also
in your founders investing them in terms
of development um
and to me the the last thing i would say
that i thought was really interesting is
that you guys build
good build good financial habits
early on before you think about what
anthony's asking for which is let's
scale like crazy because once those
financial habits
and practices of let's say getting to
profit or being
leveraged with what little cash we have
right
if you have those then putting more
money into it
gives you a lot more confidence because
they're not going to blow it right and
they're gonna ask three questions before
they spend something or do a little more
research figuring out how can i get more
maybe a two or three x versus one so i
figure i just wanted to acknowledge
that's a real
different investment mindset um and so
anthony
how have you taken that and applied it
to another huge success that everyone's
all
crazy about which is my son loves
obviously
roblox yeah soon i mean
we learned a lot of that patient
investing from from professor mcdonald
at stanford and again i i think
as larry said some of the people on this
call have probably either taken his
class or tried to take this class it's
very hard to get into his class
he taught us to be fundamentally
oriented focus on people
and be very very patient with them and
that's very hard to do in venture
capital because venture capital in
silicon valley we like to say it's like
a high school party
everybody's trying to figure out where
the cool kids are let's go
where the cool kids are the party's over
there now and we were never invited to
that party we were definitely not the
cool kids
both both in real life and as a metaphor
so we all you know we were on the
outside we had to do our own thing
and so we were looking for things that
were a little bit different and we were
willing to
take a different approach and be very
patient with them and
roblox is one of those companies that we
found way back in 2008
uh we made our first investment million
and a half dollars in february of 2008
that was more than 13 years ago and as
you know they just went public
a couple months ago so it's been a long
journey
but it's been one of the most fulfilling
journeys for us because
we found a founder and a mission that we
really just love
i mean this is this is one that that is
really impacting the world
in a big and positive way there are
hundreds of millions of kids
on this platform who are playing
together learning together learning to
code
and learning to be civil to each other
in an online environment
and so we feel like we have a big
responsibility here because we've over
that time
become the largest shareholder of the
company um it's in the wall street
journal we've invested
more than 400 million dollars into into
that company since our 1.5 and
that 400 million dollars i think today
is worth
8 billion um so that's all
that's all kind of public information
and
what one of the things we learned is
that these these
big things become bigger than we ever
think and so
it's it's just such a pleasure to be
able to work with these founders
these companies as they build out their
vision as they build up these
opportunities
another thing we talk about is
um the different kind of errors that we
can make along the way
and this was one of the questions that
came from the audience before the call
was
was that there's kind of two types of
errors that people talk about errors of
omission and arrows of commission
and i think larry was very generous when
he said you know we had made a number of
mistakes before
uh i i think we had made so many
mistakes that they probably figured out
there are no more mistakes that they
could make and
a lot of averages would take over and we
would have some successes
uh little did you know we actually had
had more mistakes to come we can talk
about that later
the the most people think making a bad
investment is the worst thing you can do
in venture capital but actually the
worst thing
you can do is missing out on a great
investment
and so uh and that applies you to even
your own companies we we invested that
one and a half million but if we didn't
invest the other 400 million afterwards
we'd be in a very different position now
so
the errors of omission can be much
greater and
much more painful both emotionally and
financially
i'll share one one story that's related
to this audience here
there was a class of 2006 student that
i was lucky enough to be the alumni
mentor for when he was at stanford gsb
and he had come from china he was he had
worked for motorola as a human resources
manager and so he knew nothing about
startups or venture capital he would
come down sand hill road to our office
right and sit in the in the conference
room where hoe is sitting right now
and once a month i would teach him about
startups
and after he graduated in 2006 he went
to singapore
where his wife was to a new country and
said i'm going to start a company
and he called me up and said would you
like to invest
i said well you know forrest i really
don't know anything about singapore it's
outside of our mandate we don't do
we don't do seed all these reasons right
well his company is called csea and is
now 100 billion dollar public company it
is the largest tech company
in southeast asia so boy that is a
painful thing that
i'm reminded about every time i look at
their stock price
wow that's wonderful so obviously we we
read about it you guys were in wall
street journal recently
tremendous success and a lot of it based
on this model that you guys have
investing in people um thinking about
the long term
building early habits and then this idea
of just continuous learning both for you
guys for you guys but also for your
companies
um you know if you think about it in
terms of managing success because that's
where you guys are
right now what what's keeping you guys
motivated now i'll end with that
question in terms of
what's keeping you guys motivated and
sort of what's next for you and
before we turn it over to the q and a
okay so um each one of you could just
sort of respond to this idea
you know what's keeping you guys
motivated and what are you guys looking
forward to
so before i answer that we
asked the same exact question of our
founders
right and it's really interesting to see
their journeys and we've had now
you know several founders become
billionaires or multi-billionaires and
we're going to have a few more
and along that journey at some point
the light bulb kind of goes off they
realize
oh i'm going to be really rich
or i'm really wealthy and you know they
don't they don't really
it doesn't register but the light bulb
goes off and then you sort of see
well what do they do with that
information right
and and you know for some folks you
might see that hey
you know they want to and now they know
what
they really want to do with their lives
and they have the freedom to go do it
they should do that they should
absolutely do that
and then there are other folks that
realize okay well that's really nice
but like this is it for me this is my
life
this is what i love to do and i'm going
right back to work
right and at some point it is no longer
about the money
uh and you know it's kind of funny
because some lps started asking us this
question
a number of years ago because maybe they
saw some of the
the the metrics and he said you guys are
going to make a lot of money like like
what's
what's driving you asking us similar
kind of questions and we thought
why are you asking us this question it's
like it's all paper gains you know
it's like like we haven't you know these
companies haven't gone public yet it's
like yeah no we're still working pretty
damn hard you know we don't really have
that much money
it's all paper and but but it got us to
start to think about this over the last
several years
and you know here we are we i think
we're on the same exact journey as some
of our founders
and they're loving what they're doing
and i think we are
kind of we are just hitting our stride
you know as bezos says it's like still
day one
in and look you know we're all doing
different work with various non-profits
and so on that's
a very important part of kind of what
our families are doing
but at the same time i've spent enough
time with these non-profits to know that
my contribution to this world is not
going to be severing on any more
non-profit boards
it's helping these entrepreneurs and
whether it works out or not if it
doesn't work out if we don't make any
money that's fine that's
part of my pro bono work right and if it
does work out
and you know the few successes more than
pay the bills
and and we're very very fortunate to be
doing what we're doing
so i'll pause there
conor anthony yeah i think on on that
theme of learning um my father who
who was a uh grew up in a village in
southern china and came to the united
states to go to
school taught me that
there's kind of three phases in life
like this is a very asian
traditional way of thinking the first
third of your life you're learning
the second third of your life you are
earning and then the third
third part the last third of your life
you're enjoying and giving back
and unfortunately he passed away when he
was 57 so he never made it to that last
third
so that model sucks is what i concluded
when
after he passed away i was like that's a
really bad model so if you can turn that
serial model
on the side and in parallel always be
learning
always be earning and always be giving
back and enjoying what you're doing
well that is a great life and i think
that is what
ho and han and i have been able to put
together here after
many trials and tribulations many more
of which we haven't even talked about i
mean we we barely made it through 2008
we barely made it through 2014.
in 2014 we we raised a 14 million dollar
fund
so there was a lot more to it than this
story and the roblox
story i mean they were a pretty boring
company for about 10 years in the middle
there
so i i think one of the things is really
enjoying what we do in that way because
we're always able to learn
and then the second thing i would say is
our definition of success has kind of
changed um we used to think it was very
successful when
someone else uh you know invested in one
of our companies at a higher valuation
a famous fund as han said earlier uh
and then we thought oh wow it was so
successful if one of our companies
became a quote unquote unicorn became
worth a billion dollars
and then we thought wow it's so great
now if a company can make a billion in
revenue
not just valuation and then now
more recently we thought wow isn't it
great that one of our entrepreneurs one
of our founders that we've been with for
10 20
15 years can become a billionaire by by
building this company from scratch and
then the most interesting one and the
one that's happening now is
seeing our successful founders give back
billions
donate billions um the founder of han
talked about he became the first korean
to sign the giving pledge
and we help help them out in that
process and we have other founders who
are now
philanthropists literally giving back
the billions
that they have made during the struggle
thanks anthony on you know i don't have
any more eloquent comments
after what anthony said
well okay i guess i'll do a wrap before
we go to q a there's just so much to
absorb i had
goosebumps uh frequently throughout this
conversation
what a wonderful conversation um they're
thinking i've got the best idea in the
world and i wanted to find some
group of folks to actually go on a
journey with me
hell i would have you guys in the
trenches with me
and and when we're putting the flag up
on the hill you would be the guys and so
i think that's
amazing for the audience i started out
by saying
you know let's look at it from the
perspective of what was untold
what were the untold heroes untold
supporters like larry
untold moments where you think hey all
bc funds make a ton of money right let's
all go into venture capital i
actually remember ho back in 94.95 you
know when we were graduating from
business school no one i mean what was
venture capital i think it was kind of a
strange animal right
um and now it's so popular but this idea
to actually get to where you guys got to
and all the near-death experiences um
just the untold stories of those okay
and how the
the untold lessons that you guys learn
and and the continuous
learning that came from it you know is
is truly incredible and i feel like uh
han you were talking about how
uh you know you get to meet with great
people and their
potential head speakers in the future or
visionaries
i feel the very same way uh having this
conversation with you guys so
thank you guys for what you guys are
doing for the community and
with that i'm going to turn it over to
ivy who's got probably
400 questions because we have 700 people
online
listening to this so ivy to you
thank you soon
and the first question actually goes to
larry
so larry what has been your experience
founding and leading fairview capital
with the
conviction and the mission to support
underrepresented groups
and how has that thinking made your firm
different
from your from your peers i'll say for
thank you
ivy for the question um
i would like to say that um
our path in this business has spawned uh
multiple imitators um
that's not true there have been a few
there have been some that have come and
gone quite frankly
we would deem success seeing many more
and even greater success quite frankly
seeing the
capital markets begin to behave in the
manner in which we're all taught
in school they behave that capital flows
to
compelling ideas and really talented
people
and if you marry the two capital will
follow
irrespective of superficial
uh sort of phenotype and again packaging
um it has been quite frankly a
challenging path
uh ivy i mentioned that we closed our
first fund back in
1994 just shy of 100 million and while
we managed
uh 10 billion today and while i i could
say
truthfully capital raising over
that time has gotten a bit easier
it has not gotten easy and it's still
the case today
where we find even after
27 years and a very long track record
now
of funds that have outperformed
um you would think that the capital
would simply flow
and that's that's just not the case and
we don't spend a lot of time
thinking about our dwelling on that um
we simply believe in what we're doing
we've got a team of really talented
capable people in our firm that we all
enjoy
working with one another we get really
charged when we're able to
back a team like the altos team and they
go on and demonstrate
exactly what you know our thesis was all
about
um just really talented people
finding terrific opportunities in
entrepreneurs and backing them and
building
world-class companies so as long as we
can
continue to to to do that ivy i think
we'll stay on the playing field
and we've been fortunate to layer our
firm with kind of multi-generations of
talent
if you will at some point my partner and
i will you know step to the sidelines
but like the altos guys
we enjoy what we're doing and as long as
we're doing it and we're not dribbling
in our soup and
our younger partners aren't asking us to
you know be pushed out the door
we'll continue doing it so i hope that
answers your question
absolutely thank you so much larry for
the sharing it's a pleasure
hey larry you raised a really
fascinating point
you guys have an amazing track record 27
years
and yet fundraising is still not easy
and
you know i've kind of come to the
conclusion that there are
you know you can't let that bother you
basically there are there are people so
many people
today with warren buffett's 50 some year
track record saying oh
he doesn't get it like whatever you know
like people will kind of their people
are irrational i mean you talk about
their they are irrational so they
there are people like larry and then
many others
uh who were part of our first couple of
funds
that backed us with no track record or
maybe a bad track record
right and then now that we have this
amazing track record
i will tell you there are still people
who will find all kinds of reasons
to not invest in us and we've we
basically learned to not take that
personally
at all it's just you know good luck
you know everybody kind of has their own
approach and they will
rationalize and they will use the data
in whatever way they want to support
whatever they want to believe in
right and so people are irrational and
you just have to believe in what you're
doing
and you got to go for it and you know if
they're going to be always naysayers
right it doesn't matter like you're
going to achieve some level of success
and you think everybody
is going to think you're great it's like
no no no i don't think so you know
they're always doubters always naysayers
you just can't let that bother you
because you know it's their life let
them live it the way they're going to
live it you live your own life
you know could not agree more home
thanks ho well we talked about the
importance of relationships earlier in
this discussion
and we're wondering um have your
experience
or your cultural backgrounds made you
think differently about managing
relationships
whether they be with your portfolio
companies with founders
with lps and with all your stakeholders
it there's many different ways to answer
that question ivy i think one thing
i would say is that and maybe this is
the immigrant mentality of it a little
bit
we never give up uh as you could tell
from our fundraising story in our
and our multiple lives as a partnership
story
we never gave up on ourselves and each
other and we never give up on our
entrepreneurs
there are companies that we've been with
now for 10
15 more years that are actually quite
small
they've never really gotten that big and
we're still
you know we still owe it to them to work
with them we love working with them
uh we call ourselves or we've been
called cockroaches
if we just keep at it we survive nuclear
winter a few times and we just keep at
it
and sometimes when you keep at it long
enough
great things and lucky things happen
actually that tells very well to the
next question which speaks to your
firm's longevity and resilience
so the economic and social environment
have changed a lot over the past few
decades
and also has stood strong after all
these years
were there any decisions investment or
otherwise that you would make
differently
looking at looking back with the
hindsight that you know now
um any things to avoid any risk or
derailers to avoid and
any thesis that would have changed from
your original thinking
yeah you know anthony alluded to this a
couple of times a little bit mistakes of
omission versus commission
i i think the look in venture capital
you're never going to lose a billion
dollars you make these little
five 10 million dollar investments you
know it could go to zero or
go to something big but we've made
multiple billion dollar mistakes
big mistakes and those are usually the
mistakes of
omission or basically selling too soon
some of our companies
and so one of the key lessons that we
learned is that it's not about the exits
and people like
larry and many of our lps they want the
liquidity they need that cash back right
because the paper we saw in the bubble
that the paper gains are worthless right
you've got to convert that
but what the key lesson we learned is
you just have to build an amazing
company
and if you do you could get liquidity
there's lots of liquidity options for
the founder for employees for investors
for our own lps
we've had liquidity through dividends
through shareholder buybacks through
secondaries
long before the ipo right so
m a exit or ipo is not the only path if
you have a great company you can get
liquidity and so we no longer think
about
getting out we think about building to
keep
and if we build and have an amazing
business we'll be able to get liquidity
if people want it
if they want to keep compounding on a
pre-tax basis that's even better and
that's kind of
one of the key things that we learned
along the way
so that we will stop making these
billion dollar mistakes right
uh han was about to say something no no
i mean i i think i think that's
that's important in that i think
sometimes
we get involved i think basically we get
involved
with a business we like but
with a founder that's sort of
questionable
and when that happens
a lot of our time basically
gets sunk with that founder and
it clouds our judgment in good companies
or any good opportunities and we miss
out on those opportunities and and i
think
sort of you know that's something you
know we keep telling ourselves that
we shouldn't do
that's great yeah well yeah when you get
involved with the wrong people it's not
the money that you lose that's
extremely costly it's it's the stress
it's the
the time sync that is going to prevent
you from finding the next great deal
there's huge costs beyond losing money
and just not worth
it to us and so we're we're just not
going to do deals because we're going to
make money like
the last thing we need is to find
another deal that just makes money
it's got to be about the people it's got
to be about the mission
and it's got to excite somebody on our
team to say i'm going to stick my neck
out and i'm going to
commit to this and i'm going to work
really hard with this company
i'm not going to let it go and if we
don't have a champion and our team to
step up to that
the deal won't happen it doesn't matter
how much money we think we're going to
make somebody has to step up to commit
to that company
and that founder and and for one of us
to step
up it has to be something more than just
making money right it's got to be
something special that we're excited
about
that's great that also leads to the next
question very well which is
would you have any advice especially
given your experience and challenges
earlier in your career any advice for
people from underrepresented groups
be it people of color or women or any
groups that are currently
underrepresented in the startup
ecosystem
i i think it just goes back to what i
said like you can't let
what the naysayers say bother you at all
they're going to be some people who are
going to be skeptical of who you are and
what you can do and it doesn't matter if
you have an amazing track record or if
if you've done so many things they will
find different
excuses or reasons why oh well you got
lucky on that one
and you're not going to repeat that
success you can't let that bother you
and you just have to you know go out
and and you have to find your people
basically you know it's quality over
quantity i think
i think that's kind of one of the things
we've learned over time we have both
quantity and quality
but all we care about is quality to be
to be honest and
you know larry's been to many of our
annual meetings i think more than 10
years ago
somebody made the comment it's like wow
these are kind of strange annual
meetings there's a lot of hugging going
on
you know it's not relationships and
bonds with our founders and
entrepreneurs and and our lp's we just
value those relationships it's just
a lot more fun that way find your people
and start from there
you don't have to convert everybody
and how do you discern that quality from
your founder is it from
the early conversations with him with
them obviously before you invest
and even after you invest continue to
influence them in their thinking
so that so that you're really shaping
their character
yeah i think you know when we invest
it's not like one conversation or two
three conversation it's multiple
conversation
and it's not like any single person
it's multiple people within the
partnership
spend time with the founder and the team
and then we try to get to
we try to get to know the entire team
and we talk about the team we talk about
sort of pluses and minuses and
and then then we get excited if we get
excited we invest
but after we invest i think that's when
we really get to know the founder a
little bit better
right we look at the decisions that they
make
and we talk about those decisions what
then we
start to understand a little bit more
about the founder
in which basically it gets us
less excited or more excited uh
about the business and the founders
long-term potential
and and you know so it's a constant
i don't want to say evaluation but it
you know it's more of a fit between
founder and us as well uh
and so there's i'm sure the founder does
the same thing
uh with our fund as well so it's a
devaluation process both two ways
yeah yeah it's it's kind of complicated
you know it's like a marriage
right you know we follow some of these
companies for a decade or more and
in over the course of 10 years people
you know will make mistakes and there
are many opportunities to disappoint
each other and you work through it and
and the relationship
gets stronger or it gets weaker and if
the relationship
gets stronger and the business is
performing those are the companies that
were likely to
double down triple down go really big
and there are other companies where we
might make a lot of money
but it's not going to be one of those
that we are going to be
really loading up on and we could all
part ways as friends
and we've you know we've made our money
and then we move on
right but there are other relationships
that endure sometimes
across multiple companies we've had we
have many folks that we've worked with
across two three
i don't know if we had a fourth one but
many people we've worked across multiple
companies over the years
and it's just very enjoyable uh to us
so that's great uh there's a question
coming in live
uh regarding any differences in terms of
the way uh startups pitch to you if they
were coming from asia versus coming from
the u.s
and any differences in the way you
evaluate them
and maybe you take that one yeah i i
think i think we go
we we look at both businesses the same
with the same lens you know we we talk
about
you know why there's an opportunity uh
you know what opportunity is it
so we have to understand it and then we
talk about
how big do we think it could be how big
does the entrepreneur think
it could be uh and then we say
you know why is the opportunity
opportunity available now
versus you know five years ago or maybe
five years from now
so we ask about that timing question and
then
then we evaluate the founder in terms of
our founding team
how good of a team is there
to execute against the opportunity and
and and that's sort of the standard
thing i'm pretty sure
every venture fund does and we do pretty
much the same thing
and we try to get a little bit more at
the character
of the founder because i think we've
been through
so many companies that we just know a
lot of difficult things will happen
the business will never go in straight
line and we have to ask ourselves
is this the person we and so we'll wrap
our official q a
period with one last question which is
what advice would you give to the
recent graduating class and the next
generation
this is the graduating class business
school or college
what about both
oh my advice might be don't take my
advice
well look i'll go back to this there are
two things that we used to tell each
other
all the time and i had to kind of bring
it back from my memory bank because we
don't say it
these days and the reason is we're not
making these kinds of mistakes
and and and we have to kind of remind
our younger generation
in our team what they were so there were
two things one was don't do stupid
things
now it's like that is like such a what
the hell does that mean it's like well
just think about
what are the things that you can do that
kind of will ruin your reputation or
land you in jail or
break relationships break trust what are
the
dumb things that you could possibly do
well
stop doing it that's one basic thing
there's a lot of stupidities in this
world
and we used to kind of say don't do
those things don't do stupid things
there's a lot of bad behavior including
burning a lot of money
and and hosing too much money into
little companies too soon that screws up
the culture and you never get a chance
to build a great one so that's one
the other is something that han used to
say all the time
he doesn't say it anymore because i
think we've gotten better probably
and it's just like it is what it is
he used to always say that it's like it
is what it is you know whatever if
something upsets you
something you know takes you off your
game or whatever it is like
like why why are you fretting over this
thing
right you have to accept it accept
reality for what it is and because we
went through so many difficult times
i think that's when that's why han used
to say that a lot
at least i remember that it is what it
is like deal with it
right so those are two like little
things that we used to say a lot within
our partnership
way back when we no longer say those
kinds of things
but those are two very important basic
pieces of advice that i would encourage
people to think about
no you know i i it's it's funny it's
um we used to i used to talk about that
with jack mcdonald
uh and and jack always said hey
admitting the reality is sort of or
mistake or reality is the first step
towards
fixing whatever you've done wrong right
so
without admitting it there's no way
you're gonna be able to fix anything
so we actually look for that in the
entrepreneurs
you know do they actually tell the
reality as
is or do they tell the reality
as they hope the reality might be
and it's a very important distinction
it's it is a
intellectual honesty so you we want
that intellectual honesty from all the
entrepreneurs
but like if if somebody's graduating
from college
i would say go to a place where they
work you
like 120 hours a week i mean
i think you you deserve to be at a place
where
you just work hard and i think there's
something to be gained by
being at a place where you just work so
hard and it gets ingrained in you
and i think it's you know maybe the best
habit
you will have for the rest of your life
my girls really adhere to that but
well thank you again ho han anthony and
larry
thank you so much for sharing your
experience insights
wisdom with us this evening and chris
i'll pass it back to you
thank you ivy thank you ho
han anthony and larry for an inspired
conversation
your candor and generosity ensuring your
experience
and wisdom demonstrate that our
communities
are stronger when we work together the
altos origin story
its humble beginnings seeking unlikely
allies
applying lessons learned from the tough
times
and managing success in a humble
and service frame of mind are lessons
that we can all take
through our minds and our hearts and
thank you again soon and ivy
for your panel q a in moderation it was
fantastic
a video of today's panel will be made of
anal bull later this month
our next gsb asian alumni chapter event
is only a week
away we will be hosting a panel titled
from anger to action a round table with
asian ceos this panel will feature the
ceos
of ancestry open table and hyphen
capital
leaders who will share their
observations and personal experiences
with bias and discrimination
learn how they translate their anger
with anti-asianism
into productive actions that will drive
short
and long-term impactful changes at home
at work and in the community the
speakers will share their
recommendations for what asians and
allies can do i'll post the link in the
chat box
in a bit and on a related note um
my gsb classmate norman chen co-founder
and chief executive of the non-profit
leading asian americans to unite for
change
or also called launch recently released
a landmark survey that is among the most
comprehensive
of its kind to assess attitudes about
asian americans
who number close to 23 million in the
united states today
i'll also post a link to that report in
the chat box and encourage you to take a
look at that
so as we come to the 90-minute mark i'd
like to thank all of you all our
attendees for joining tonight
and i hope we see you again soon for
those of you who like
to stay on a little while longer we'll
pivot to an optional
off the record extra 15 minutes or so of
q a
that ivy and soon will lead ivy and soon
you can take it from here and i'll pause
and stop the record button
thank you thank you larry thank you guys
all right thank you everybody